who surprised you who support you in a
way that you never you know what there
been a lot I will say the thing the
thing I struggle with is there's a lot
of folks who supported me but they
weren't willing to do it publicly and
that's the hard part because frankly
that's what I needed and I don't mean if
you catch someone on a red carpet
because like Jamie Foxx was wonderful
they caught him on a red carpet and he
was like this is what comedy should be
and it was so meaningful to me because
he's like legit and everybody loves him
and he's an Oscar winner is like thank
you
I still love Kathy Griffin I will say
that I got a really really helpful and
lovely call from Canadian Jim Carrey and
he said words that really turned out to
be true he said Cathy today and I was
sobbing sobbing I barely know Jim I'm
sobbing he goes Cathy today you're the
most famous comedian in the world use it
and he goes do you know how many
comedians would give their right arm to
have this story it is the job of a
comedian to cross the line at all times
well Jim and Jamie both spoke o2 et
saying they supported Cathy others did
so more quietly I hope you know who my
real live next-door neighbors were get
ready Kim kardashian-west and Kanye
Kardashian West five feet away we could
like wave to each other for the window
and you know I would get like text from
Kim that she was praying for me Kanye
and I would have conversations that were
you know I I think it is way I'm sure he
meant to be supportive but sometimes he
would just smile like that so just that
alone like I'm under an investigation
I'm getting calls from the Department of
Justice
Kim and Kanye are next door beeping in
there be good that's right
Cathy's family even received death
threats including her sister Joyce who
passed away from cancer four months
after the incident is the word to
describe what that added to this whole
ordeal you know during this quote ordeal
yeah my sister passed away from a slow
and horrible cancer I shaved my head in
solidarity with her like I said the idea
that my sister was getting death threats
when she was dying of cancer is heinous
it's unbelievable and it's another
reason that I'm like oh no I'm gonna get
there and I'm gonna tell this story now
Cathy's telling those stories on a lap
your head off world tour and her tales
about Trump have a personalized twist
it's also the fact that I've known trunk
for 20 years and I have one story in my
act of an amount of like it had to be at
least 45 minutes where I was in a space
this big with just the Donald and Liza
Minnelli and so that's just worth buying
the ticket alone just imagining Liza who
may have taken a happy pill I don't
judge and you know that's like a unique
thing like I've had Trump stories
frankly kind of sitting in my drawer
because nobody really cared about him he
was just the host of The Apprentice than
a buffoon but now he's the accidental
president Oh also do you think do you
think that when Ivanka sees your prime
minister do you think she does like the
one shoulder off cuz she's getting she's
gonna be got ready Jared he's very heavy
he's very handsome but you can tell
she's like oh did I pick the wrong one
she would make that switch in a
heartbeat I know her in a heartbeat she
would oh she would be Ivanka Trudeau in
one day in one day yeah she's shallow
she's not like a she's not a stable
genius as they say if Trump is in front
of you and you could say one thing to my
would you say off off your piece of you
stupid piece of game you're gonna kick
up I'm gonna kick him and then I'm gonna
kick him again